hi there Steve here since I'm in Palm
Springs I thought I would do a little
video out here you know our yard you'll
see the nice flowers the Suns in my eyes
I'm gonna talk about online tutors and
how to get the most out of online tutors
now the world of language learning has
changed dramatically in fact the Sun is
really in my eyes here so I'm gonna move
a little bit there we go you know the
world of language learning has changed
so dramatically because the classroom we
used to go to a class we have a teacher
we have classmates and we would follow
whatever the program was that the
teacher was was following the curriculum
whereas now you have this this wide
array of of online language learning
systems including link of course and
many others you have a tremendous amount
of content resources dictionaries and of
course you have tutors offering their
services
I have often used the services of eye
talkie and but now recently I've tended
to where possible use our tutors link
and we have improved and sort of
revamped dark our system for connecting
our learners with with tutors now how do
we get the most out of it first of all
let me say that I have in the past had
online tutors even though I am a great
believer in input based learning and
typically my strategy has been to work
on input until I get to a level of where
I have enough vocabulary that I can say
something meaningful that I can
understand what it said and and but this
was it obviously varies now in the case
of Arabic it takes longer to get to
where you have that vocabulary because
of the difficulties of the writing
system and so forth but and if I started
Arabic some time in I don't know almost
a year ago it was only in August that I
started talking to people online with
our tutors that link
in the case of Farsi I started much
earlier because we don't have
text-to-speech and so I wanted to have
someone help me read these texts and so
I connected with a tutor in Farsi now I
have spoken to tutors in Polish in Greek
in Czech in Romanian and I can still
remember my polish teacher who lives in
Krakow and in Ukrainian our Ukrainian
teacher he lives in l'viv of course in
Arabic I had a teacher who was a Syrian
refugee located in Turkey I had a person
from Kuwait who was a student in Spain
and now I have this excellent tutor from
Egypt and I'm talking to him every day
what I do is when we talk and
particularly ibrahim in' in egypt he
makes copious notes of all of the words
and phrases that i struggled to find or
that I use incorrectly and then this is
sent to me as a report and and in fact
he's now started recording these and so
these are words and phrases that are
very alive to me because his these are
things that I tried to say and so when I
go back to him the next day you know I
still forget the same words I still make
the same mistakes but I'm slowly
improving thanks to this sort of
engagement with content that's very
meaningful to me this morning I went
through all of my conversation reports
which these these are imported as
lessons into link and I go back to
August and I can still remember this is
with this this student female student
from Kuwait who was living in Spain and
I can still remember our conversations
and so you can actually rehash your
conversations rehash the vocabulary you
discovered that some of the words that
were introduced then in which you
learned that you subsequently forgot you
are now coming across them again in
conversation and so I'm able to read and
more than once sort of go over again
these conversations so it's a
tremendously
useful way to not only get me speaking
but also helped me with my input based
learning and and not only that I'm able
to connect with Egypt with Syrian
refugee in Turkey with a Kuwaiti or yes
Kuwaiti living in Spain with with a
person in Warsaw Berlin Prague and very
often I follow up then with a visit as I
did in the case of Prague and l'viv
visit to where these people live and
then we have additional encounters there
so it's a way of engagement oh and I
should add while I'm talking about
online tutors and resources available on
the Internet
one of my favorite dictionaries and we
connect to it at Lync is context
reversal because they have a a
conjugating dictionary they even have it
available for Arabic but it seems to be
very hit and miss very often I'll look
up a verb and I get 404 you know URL not
found but when I do found find it of
course I get a complete review of the
conjugation of that verb I know it works
very well in Spanish in French and even
in Hebrew in other languages what that
enables you to do because verbs are so
important that yet in many cases so
difficult you can kind of review them
the range of of conjugations of forms of
the verb get the form that you're
looking for go back to the texture
reading and and you've that little bit
of review review just helps me get a
picture of how that verb works so hats
off to context reversal oh and by the
way now at link when you save a verb the
verb will automatically automatically be
tagged as verb it'll tell you what tense
that is and what person that is so you
get a lot of additional information
about the verb this is extremely useful
because sometimes if you're new to the
language you don't even know that it's a
verb and you certainly don't know which
form of the verb it is so that's now
available so these are the kinds of
resources and functions that are
available on the sort of internet-based
language-learning world of which the
online tutor and there's more and more
of them ISM is a major part and I'm
looking forward to my conversation with
Ibrahim this evening at for my time so
thank you for listening just sorry for
squinting and now I will see if I can
turn this off here
[Music]